networks will put just about anything on
television from a naked dating show to
documenting a woman 600-pound life the
more extreme the better if you want some
serious bonus points
throw in some shocking story lines here
are a few of TV's most controversial
plots Game of Thrones sexual assault no
stranger to controversy won Game of
Thrones Season 5 episodes left fans
calling for a boycott Suns a stark
played by sophie turner was sexually
assaulted on her wedding night by her
new husband Ramsay Bolton who also
forced the sons as childhood friends
Theon Greyjoy to watch from the corner
tough to watch yes tough to act out
apparently not Turner revealed to
Entertainment Weekly when I read that
scene I kind of loved it I loved the way
Ramsay had fee on watching it was also
messed up fans did not all agree and US
Senator Claire McCaskill decided to
publicly announce a boycott of the show
the newsroom's campus rape in HBO's the
newsroom Don played by Thomas sadoski
goes to a college campus to interview a
female student who and created a website
to out rapists anonymously after she was
raped herself Don is supposed to find
out more information about the woman but
for many reasons he ends up discouraging
her from going on his new show to debate
her attacker this led to an attack on
series creator Aaron Sorkin according to
the New York Times viewers felt Sorkin
was victim blaming women and showing
more concern about the after effects of
a man who was wrongly accused of rape
sortin responded in an interview with
The Observer I'm saying I knew that one
of the stories was controversial and I'm
not someone who courts controversy so I
was a little surprised with vitriol and
misunderstanding this morning of what
was going on in that episode and
terrible inferences drawn from it about
me personally Sons of Anarchy school
shooting there are a lot of over-the-top
gruesome scenes and Sons of Anarchy but
when a young boy brings a kg-9 machine
gun to his elementary school opening
fire on his classmates and teachers
that's when fans thought the show really
crossed the line the episode aired just
nine months after the Sandy Hook
elementary school shooting so the scene
hit a little too close to home for some
series creator Kurt Sutter defended the
value of the scene at TV Guide saying I
believe that it's about mental illness
which is why I layered that in I believe
it's about parent neglect which is why I
Laird batted I believe it's about the
gun laws and illegal guns in the street
all those things contribute to that
perfect storm the Ellen shows coming-out
episode in April 1997
Ellen DeGeneres in her sitcom Ellen
changed
in history when her character also named
Ellen and based on herself came out on
national television even though she only
publicly come out a few days earlier in
Time magazine it was still a risky move
in the late 90s only a handful of
scripted show starred gay characters and
the approval rating for gay marriage was
at a low 27 percent advertisers
reportedly started pulling their ads
from the show although only Chrysler
actually admitted to it
setting a corporate policy to avoid
controversial clients all coming out on
TV wasn't the popular thing to do at the
time Ellen said she didn't do it to make
herself a standard bearer for the gay
community
she just had to do it for herself South
Park and Mohamad South Park is not
afraid to go to extremes to get laughs
when the show's creators Matt Stone and
Trey Parker tried using an image of the
islamic prophet muhammed it was like all
hell broke loose well after the episode
ran the following quote appeared on a
pro jihadi website targeting the
creators of South Park we have to warn
Matt and Trey they are the creators that
what they are doing is stupid and they
will probably wind up like Theo van Gogh
though an image of Muhammad had aired
before a network block of show runners
run using a visual of the Prophet due to
recent world events and safety concerns
did not make stoner Parker happy campers
so rather than showing a picture of
Muhammad they posted a message on screen
reading quote Comedy Central has refused
to broadcast an image of Muhammad on
their network thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos of the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which TV flops surprised you the
most
you